oh my gosh I'm sorry to tell you this
guy's but coconut oil is a poison yes
it's very very dangerous I know it's
been given to a lot of cultures over the
last 2,000 years and they didn't have a
problem but so it's now just been
recognized by the experts that is very
very dangerous
okay guys coconuts are only dangerous if
they're traveling at your head and you
don't duck okay that's the only danger
in a coconut guys let me just show you
why Bay well I'm just trying to figure
who they is consider coconut oil a
poison because if the saturated fat now
they didn't do studies then having you
consume coconut oil and having it cause
heart attack now
they just ignored that link and went
right to the saturated fats okay because
everyone knows that consuming saturated
fats will clog your arteries and cause
coronary heart disease I mean that's a
fact right that is an example of false
data okay that is false information now
the American Heart Association blasted
out there to all the physicians that you
need to start replacing the saturated
fat type products with the vegetable
oils okay so that's kind of like the the
new thing but what they ignored is these
three very large studies the Minnesota
coronary survey experiment the Sydney
study and the Women's Health Initiative
I'm going to put the links down below so
you can check them out because these
major studies do not show this link at
all okay they show that if there is not
a link there and there's a lot more as
well now let's just switch over to the
true information okay coconut oil is 70
percent medium chain triglycerides these
type of fats are very very different
they're used to make energy they're used
to be converted to ketones for energy
and then they bypass the gallbladder so
it's really a low stress fat for the
liver in the gallbladder 50% of coconut
oil is lauric acid which has amazing
antimicrobial properties it's great for
the immune system
and by the way some of the studies that
the American Heart
Association used to prove this link is
they're not just using saturated fats
these diets were also higher
carbohydrate diets and if you mix higher
carbohydrates with high protein or fat
you're gonna get this result right here
it's the carbohydrate okay it's the
sugar here's the truth the coconut oil
industry did not pay off I'm sorry
sponsor the American Heart Association
like some of the other industries like
the food industry and the drug industry
which basically spent five hundred and
twenty-one million dollars that was in
actually 2011 and 2012 I'm not sure what
it is now but they basically spent a lot
of money to get the stamp of approval
okay and there's something else called
the heart check food certification where
the American Heart Association basically
endorses different products that they
are heart-healthy and I think you have
to spend something like seven hundred
thousand dollars a year just to have
that endorsement anyway you don't have
to worry about coconut oil being
poisonous it's actually a very very
healthy it's been around for a long time
and there's also quite a few studies
that show that it actually lowers your
cholesterol I'm gonna put those links
down below now go ahead and comment
below and tell me what your thoughts are
on this so we've been getting a lot of
success stories but I don't have your
success story yet so click the link down
below and upload your before and after I
want to actually hear about your success
story I want to see your
before-and-afters and every week we do
featured success stories so click the
link down below and share your success